m
et
où
florence place santa croce cette parade
précède un jeu médiéval qui se déroule
chaque année
aussi la samarie l'économie
le football sport de l'aristocratie
italienne à l'époque de la renaissance
plonge ses racines dans l'évolution des
fondements du football anglais
les 25 joueurs de chaque équipe doivent
respecter des règles précises avec une
grande loyauté
en italie le football a une tradition
séculaire à florence les rouges
affrontent les verts c'est en italie que
les joueurs endossent pour la première
fois des maillots aux couleurs utilisées
dans le football moderne
le jeu historique du mur un iphone
collège est tout sauf délicat c'est dans
cette école anglaise qui est né le
football moderne c'est un jeu dont les
règles autorise les usages des mains et
des pratiques assez violente
les représentants de nombreux clubs de
rugby attire l'attention sur le fait que
la plupart de leurs membres souhaitent
retourner à leur travail de lundi sans
avoir les os brisés
deux tendances s'affrontent c'est ainsi
que naissent en 1863 deux associations
celle du football et celle du rugby avec
l'institution d'une fédération
le football devient vite un sport de
masse
1910 naissance du suffrage universel
le football ce sport populaire devient
aussi un instrument de propagande
que newcastle joue contre bradford
n'intéresse pas réellement les partis
politiques mais le match attire
l'attention des milliers de spectateurs
c'est l'occasion de se faire voir le
foot devient un enjeu de la lutte
électorale
même le premier ministre se déplace une
habitude chère aux politiciens qui se
maintient encore de nos jours
oh
berlin 10 912 finale pour la coupe du
prince héritier d'un empire les équipes
n'appartiennent pas à des sociétés ce
sont des équipes régionales
berlin contre l'allemagne du sud
l'équipe berlinoise dgb l'emportent 6 à
défilé pour l'inauguration des jeux
olympiques de stockhom de 1912
lors du match allemagne autriche le
gardien de but allemand weber continue à
jouer malgré une commotion cérébrale et
laisse passer trois buts faciles à
arrêter avant de perdre connaissance
score 5-1 pour l'autriche
l'équipe allemande bat la russie 16 à 0
un résultat fantastique
le gouvernement du tsar refuse de payer
le voyage de retour à ses joueurs
après les danois les plus farouches
adversaires des anglais sont les
hollandais
avec un score de 2 à 0 pour la troisième
fois les anglais sont vainqueur aux jeux
olympiques
en 1920 le roi albert de belgique
inaugure les premiers jeux olympiques
d'après guerre le très jeune joueur
espagnol zamora commence sa carrière il
sera le plus grand gardien de but du
monde pendant 15 ans
les espagnoles rencontrent la suède
pour finir deux jours après les belges
sont déclarés vainqueurs parce que les
tchécoslovaques après une bagarre ont
abandonné le terrain en signe de
protestation
amérique du sud le match argentine
uruguay de 1922 intéresse peu l'europe
cela étant ces équipes feront bientôt
parler d'elle
l'unique homme de couleur de l'équipe
andré andrade l'homme aux pieds d'or
fascine son public en particulier les
dames
après le match il reste quatorze jours à
paris et se lie d'amitié avec joséphine
baker
la presse décrit le jeu des russes comme
une symphonie un mélange d'art et de
force d'élégance et d'esprit de rapidité
de résistance de rythme et de ruse de
beauté et de puissance de tir
3-0 pour l'uruguay dans la finale contre
la suisse alors la plus forte équipe
d'europe
berlin stade de grunwald 50000
spectateurs assistent à l'entrée des
représentants des fédérations de
football à l'occasion du championnat
d'allemagne de 1926
lors du match aller laërt abs et
l'emportent sur la société sportive
hambourgeoise
quatre ans auparavant a eu la finale la
plus grotesque qui puisse exister
le match a duré quatre heures jusqu'à ce
que l'obscurité de la nuit empêche les
joueurs de voir le ballon
n'en pouvant plus l'arbite c'était
troubler le jeu était suspendu seulement
jusqu'au moment où il est revenu à lui
c'est les repas qui bat en bo 4 à 2
cette victoire enthousiasme autant les
berlinois que la saveur police
prussienne est impuissant ton contre le
joyeux tohu bull
wembley 1932 newcastle united joue
contre arsenal fc le match entrera dans
les annales et sera fort controversé
seconde décisive botte de newcastle
envoie le ballon devant les buts
il y dévié par un autre joueur qui
marque le but est validé mais le ballon
était auparavant sorti du terrain
cependant la décision prise par
l'arbitré est entérinée et le match
continue
la même année un lieu la rencontre du
siècle angleterre autriche
à cette époque ce sont les deux équipes
nationales les plus fortes d'europe
pour la première fois les anglais sont
vaincus sur le propre sol 3 à 4
1934 rhum deuxième coupe du monde fina
l'italie tchécoslovaquie le capitaine de
l'équipe et pepino médecin mussolini et
là il est décidé à faire de la victoire
des footballeurs italiens un succès
politique
il y à 60000 spectateurs
larbitre et le suédois est clean
les tchécoslovaques semble dominer le
match grâce à leur gardien de but plan k
qui fait des miracles en arrêtant les
tirs des stars du football italien
or si est monté
1 0 pour les tchécoslovaques à une
minute de la fin
or si égalise pour l'italie larbitre
fait jouer les prolongations
c'est ce caveau qui marque le but et
offre à l'italie la prestigieuse coupe
coupe du monde 1938 le comité de la
fédération internationale de football
pose pour la photo de rigueur la fifa a
été créée en 1904 suite à une demande
unanime son fondateur et jules rimet
lors des éliminatoires s'affrontent la
suisse et l'équipe nationale de la
grande allemagne deux formations
aguerries qui n'ont pas l'habitude de
reculer le commentaire du présentateur
laisse déjà présager du résultat
l'un des grands intérêts de ce mac est
de savoir comment s'appellera la fusion
entre les représentants de deux styles
opposés et d'allemand football mais la
pulsion d'éthylotests réellement n'est
pas parfait gauche elle l'avant-centre
allemand marque mais le suisse très lo
abegglen égalise d'un coup de tête tout
est à recommencer
dans le deuxième match les amants qui
sont favoris se font battre 4 à 2 par
les helvètes qui se qualifie pour le
quart de finale
les allemands sont désemparés à des
glens toujours lui marca troisième but
très long et le héros du jour pour
l'allemagne du troisième page c'est une
véritable gifle l'allemagne disparaît de
la compétition voici les indonésiens à
l'époque l'archipel est encore une
colonie hollandaise
c'est la première fois que l'asie est
représentée à la coupe du monde les
nouveaux arrivants n'ont pas compris
qu'ils n'avaient aucune chance face à
leurs onze adversaires et sont battus 6
à 0 par la hongrie
les brésiliens sont favoris parmi les
favoris grâce en particulier à leur star
leonidas il déploie une remarquable
tactique et dominent les polonais qui
dans la première mi-temps essaient de
résister aux assauts de leurs
adversaires encouragé par le prodigieux
leonidas
mais c'est seulement lors des
prolongations que le buteur brésilien le
diamant noir comme on l'a surnommé
marque le penalty décisif le public et
les commentateurs brésilien exultent
leur équipe nationale à remporter la
victoire
une première pour l'époque
lors de la finale l'italie joue contre
la hongrie qui aurait pu avoir comme
adversaire le brésil mais l'entraîneur
des sud américains sûrs de la victoire a
privé son équipe de léonidas pendant la
demi finale contre l'italie afin de le
réserver pour la finale sans son favori
le brésil a perdu 2 1
la finale se transforme en un duel entre
les deux plus grands attaquants de tous
les temps l'italien piero là et le
hongrois s'arroser
buts de piola
attaquant hongrois but de s'arroser à la
fin de la première mi temps
l'italie mène 3-1
colas et a marqué deux buts piola marque
son 2e but 4 à 2 pour l'italie explosion
de joie de porto qui verse quelques
larmes et de peppino mais axa qui reçoit
la coupe du monde
il retournera en italie où elle était
déjà depuis quatre ans où elle restera
encore quatre ans jusqu'en 1942 du
rassemblement mondial des footballeur de
toutes nationalités
je n'écoute pas il n'y aura pas de coupe
du monde de football en 1942 car c'est
de nouveau la guerre ce sont les soldats
qui organisent leur propre match de foot
comme ces prisonniers allemands en
angleterre
parmi les prisonniers qui sont restés en
angleterre berne trautmann devient le
huitième joueur de l'année
lors de la finale de la coupe le gardien
de but de manchester city se fait mal
aux cervicales
pendant le match il prend de dangereux
coup de ballon et va de plus en plus mal
il continue tout de même à jouer mais
son équipe finit par le contraindre à
abandonner la coupe
trois ans plus tard manchester united
rend hommage aux infirmiers et aux
médecins qui ont soigné les survivants
de la catastrophe de munich lors de
laquelle la quasi totalité de l'équipe a
trouvé la mort parmi les survivants
il y à bobby charlton et matt busby
l'entraîneur un message de busby est
enregistrée à l'hôpital est diffusée
dans le stade
ce qui menace la zone europe stable à ce
qu'est ce que c'est
sept ans après une autre catastrophe des
cimes une équipe entière les meilleurs
joueur du torino périssent dans
l'accident de leur avion qui s'écrase
sur la basilique de superga
cinq cent mille personnes le président
de la république et l'ensemble du
gouvernement le rendent hommage
toute l'italie ce recueil tandis que le
commentateur les noms des victimes sur
les corbillards sens là
fanning cave et gramat
crétin la une
on appelle les
men
mon père est mon
en 1950 un an après la catastrophe
aérienne de superga l'équipe italienne
par pourri au afin de participer à la
coupe du monde à bord les possibilités
de s'entraîner sont limitées et la
nourriture est très bonne trop les
champions du monde seront éliminés au
premier tour au brésil
le foot est le sport par excellence deux
cent mille spectateurs prennent d'assaut
les gradins du maracana le plus grand
stade du monde
le match entre les états unis et
l'angleterre est particulièrement
passionnant le 29 juin une fringante
sélection anglaise fait ses débuts dans
la coupe comptant sur le talent de
joueurs qui ont fait leurs preuves
mais un coup de tête de gadgets
attaquant des états unis portent un coup
à l'orgueil des anglais un résultat
particulièrement vexant pour le pays qui
a inventé le football moderne
finale brésil l'uruguay le brésil est
bien placé pour être champion du monde
il a incontestablement la meilleure
équipe
les brésiliens sont déjà en train de
fêter le titre qu'ils sont sûrs de
remporter
un silence de mort tombe sur les deux
cent vingt mille spectateurs qu'en ce
cas finaux a égalisé pour l'uruguay
on s'attend à ce qu'à de mire considéré
comme l'un des meilleurs joueurs du
monde
sauve la mise aux brésiliens à onze
minutes de la fin gilles ya un milieu de
terrain uruguayen marque un but et ses 2
elle remporte pour la seconde fois le
titre mondial
les joueurs du brésil quitte le terrain
en pleurs des centaines de spectateurs
restent pendant des heures sur les
gradins atterré
prostrés brio le brésil tout entier sont
comme paralysés
lors de la rencontre angleterre hongrie
billy wright et puskas nous font vivre
un moment historique du football 1953
pour la première fois les anglais sont
battus sur leur propre terrain ils
reconnaissent la supériorité de la
hongrie leur légendaire fair play est
apprécié des commentateurs de la radio
et de la télévision
avec sa nouvelle tactique du 4-2-4
l'équipe de puskas sème la confusion
parmi les footballeur anglais
arrive le jour de la coupe du monde
berne 1954 la suisse joue contre
l'italie les helvètes parts dans
l'optique des jeux olympiques de 1934
buts de julie lors du quart de finale
ils ont été battus 7 à 5 par l'autriche
et ont failli être éliminé
mais maintenant il marque le quatrième
but face à l'italie la demi finale
oppose l'autriche à l'allemagne qui
l'emportent 6 1
l'uruguay qui a éliminé l'angleterre en
abattant 4 à 2 c'est devant le favori
hongrois qui s'impose 4 à 2 après les
prolongations
elle somme ne s'attend à du grand
spectacle de la part de l'allemagne au
contraire les allemands soulève
l'enthousiasmé dans le stade
buts de chefa finalement l'autriche est
battue 6 1 penalty de fritz walter
pas
finale l'entraîneur de l'équipe fédérale
ces paires bergen stratège de l'équipe
allemande examine le terrain idéal pour
fritz walter le capitaine de l'équipe
sera particulièrement à l'aise sur ce
terrain lourd la finale se déroule sous
la pluie au départ tout allait rejouer
davance les hongrois qui ont déjà battu
les allemands 8 à 3 au premier tour mène
maintenant 2 à 0 grâce à puskas
mais berg air remplace certains joueurs
risquent ans le tout pour le tout son
courage est récompensé but de morts lors
de 1
on égalise 2 à 2
entre les deux mi temps fritz walter
l'idole des supporters signe des
autographes comme les stars de cinéma
attaques des hongrois interrompu par
poesy pâle my schafer et enfin fritz
valter les allemands ont étudié les
matchs de wembley et se sont adaptés à
la nouvelle tactique des hongrois
deux minutes avant la fin ran récupère
le ballon
3 2
devant les 70000 spectateurs présents
dans le stade
les allemands deviennent champions du
monde nous sommes en 1954 après la
guerre ils ont connu une longue période
de quarantaine engendrés par la méfiance
la coupe du monde de berne redonne aux
allemands une partie de leur crédibilité
sans aucun doute grâce à une de leur
plus belle victoire une victoire
sportive stockholm 1958 la coupe du
monde s'ouvre avec le match argentine
allemagne le stade sympathise pour les
argentins
à la 3e minute corbatta marque le
premier but mais les attaques suivantes
sont arrêtés par éclairage les âmes en
contre attaque
brad marque un but égalisant schaefer
centre de la gauche en direction de ces
leurres qui marque son premier but dans
un match international
ran marque le dernier but 3 1 pour
l'allemagne
mais pendant la rencontre pour la 3e
place l'allemagne très affaibli par les
accidents survenus lors du match contre
la suède subi une cuisante défaite face
à la france
c'est surtout une victoire pour celui
qui sera considéré comme le meilleur
footballeur français de l'histoire juste
fontaine
il marque 4 buts à lui seul lors de ce
match est très au total pendant la coupe
et limitera réussi à marquer un but
incroyable
mais la joie des allemands dure peu à la
dernière minute du jeu
fontaine marque encore 6 à 3 la france
est troisième
à stockholm le terrain détrempé par la
pluie était plongée avant le
commencement de la finale brésil suède
cette partie marque les débuts d'un
jeune joueur brésilien de 17 ans
telle est la perle noire
oh
or
les 50000 spectateurs sont extrêmement
enthousiaste y compris des suédois qui
malgré des avantages de leur équipe
reconnaissent la beauté du jeu des sud
américains doivent à épauler marque deux
buts et de zagallo 1 pour le brésil
l'iedom et simonson un but chacun pour
la suède score 5 à 2 les cariocas se
remporte le championnat du monde
l'équipe embrasse le nouveau héros du
football pelé à 17 ans il est encore
permis de pleurer
la coupe du monde suivante qui se
déroule à santiago du chili en 1962 est
parfaitement bien organisée elle fera
date dans l'histoire du football
international pour des raisons qui n'ont
rien à voir avec le sport
la passion nationaliste s'enflamme
pendant le match chili italie
il n'est plus question de jeu les
italiens les chiliens s'affrontent dans
un véritable combat
les footballeurs italiens expulsé quitte
le terrain sous les scores de la police
manifestement intimidé par le fanatisme
des supporters larbitre anglais fait
sortir des bleus mais laisse les joueurs
chiliens agir impunément l'équipe
nationale chilienne fini par s'imposer 2
à 0 contre une équipe italienne amputé
de deux de ses membres
les chiliens peuvent assister au match
non seulement en venant au stade mais
aussi dans la rue la télévision est
arrivée au chili à temps pour la coupe
du monde
c'est l'attraction numéro un dans les
rues de santiago
la rencontre la plus attendue est la
finale brésil tchécoslovaquie les
tchécoslovaques semblent avoir retrouvé
leur grande forme des années 30 buts du
tchécoslovaque maso plus
et voilà le brésilien garrincha
sharif le meilleur gardien des buts du
championnat bloque le tir mais face au
fantastique jeu de l'équipe brésilienne
et à son capitaine 10 10 les
tchécoslovaques sont impuissants
amarildo zito et vava marque pour le
brésil masopust pour la tchécoslovaquie
3 le brésil est encore champions et
vainqueurs font le tour d'honneur en
portant le drapeau du pays hôte
deux ans plus tard le stade de lima au
pérou est témoin de l'une des plus
grandes tragédies de l'histoire du
football
un but non prise en compte par l'
arbitre déchaîne la colère des
supporters le terrain est envahi la
police intervient en lançant des gaz
lacrymogènes
la foule est prise de panique et la
rencontre dégénèrent en émeutes
une sorte d'hystérie collective s'empare
des spectateurs comme des policiers qui
seront sévèrement critiqués pour leurs
méthodes
le bilan est terrifiant temps le nombre
des morts et de blessés est important
wembley 1963 l'angleterre joue contre le
reste du monde à savoir la sélection de
la fifa copa pour la france schnell
inger pour l'allemagne yashin pour
l'union soviétique
santos pour le brésil pesée bio pour le
portugal
hérin tôt pour l'espagne et yahoo pour
les cosses la rencontre obéit à une
tradition les joueurs du reste du monde
sélectionnés par la fifa ne forme
évidemment pas une équipe homogène
malgré les hors classe qui la composent
ils ne réussissent pas à s'imposer à
l'équipe nationale d'angleterre
le match se termine 4 à 4
une autre attaque à cinq à la barre la
mélodie a tellement hâte en déloger
turello c'est bien beau les grands
ballets de peiner à des attaques à dacca
et lignot herrera et l'entraîneur de
l'inter il a introduit en italie de
nouvelles tactiques et des méthodes
d'entraînement inédite que les autres
clubs italiens commencent eux aussi à
adopter en peu de temps le football
italien devient l'un des plus beaux du
monde
on
l'afrique
arrivé depuis peu dans l'univers du
football commence à faire parler de ses
équipes de ses joueurs éliminatoires
pour les jeux olympique de dakar le
sénégal pays hôte affronte le nigéria
buts pour le sénégal buts et victoire du
sénégal de à les africains admire le
football les européens
le capitaine de l'équipe anglaise steurs
stanley matthews est considéré comme le
meilleur joueur
enthousiaste l'afrique lui confère un
nouveau titre de noblesse grand maître
du football
à glasgow 127 milles spectateurs
assistent au premier but de l'équipe de
francfort qui vient de voir le jour
il est marqué par crès
puis c'est le real madrid qui domine la
sgo temple du football depuis plus d'un
siècle avec son immense stade est le
lieu idéal pour la finale de la coupe
d'europe des clubs champions
l'un des plus prestigieux tournois après
la coupe du monde
buts de puskas pour le real
à
buts de stein
but du génie du football argentin di
stéfano joueur du real victoire du réal
7 à 3 londres 1966 plus de cent ans
après la fondation de la football
association date de naissance du
football moderne
la coupe du monde se déroule pour la
première fois en angleterre
et nagoya japon au début en tête les
portugais s'apprête à jouer au premier
tour contre les brésiliens détenteur du
titre
les brésiliens font le signe de croix
avant le début du match
les brésiliens sont littéralement
abasourdi par le premier but des
portugais
leur entraîneur feu là n'en croit pas
ses yeux
pelé qui est le coeur et le cerveau de
l'équipe brésilienne tombe deux fois de
suite
l'idole se retrouve à terre amerigo ma
soeur et mascotte des sud-américains se
précipite sur le terrain
l'objectif des portugais est clair
éliminer pellet pour s'assurer la
victoire
bien qu'un peu cabossée pelé recommence
à jouer mais il a énormément perdu de sa
forme
pesée bio la star du benfica de lisbonne
marque deux buts lors des prolongations
trois familles
les calculs des portugais se sont
révélées justes nous et but est baptisé
le pôle et européens un peu les
européens de la même couleur que le
footballeur brésilien un noir du
mozambique un africain qui bat un noir
sud américain
les reporters transmettre l'événement le
brésil a perdu
la deuxième surprise arrive de la corée
du nord
à leur arrivée les joueurs ne sont pas
connues et les italiens ne les prennent
pas au sérieux
c'est comme ça que ces inconnus venus
d'asie commence à éliminer les plus
grands footballeurs italiens
1 0 pour la corée du nord
en italie la défaite est vécu comme une
humiliation nationale
à leur tour les joueurs sont bombardés
de tomates
snelling heures qui joue à milan fait
une passe à allaire de l'équipe de
bologne avec deux joueurs appartements
des clubs italiens
l'allemagne rencontre l'union soviétique
arrivé en demi finale yashin lui même le
meilleur gardien de but d'avant guerre
ne peut rien faire pour arrêter le tir
de beckenbauer 2 1 dans un geste
éminemment sportif yashin félicite les
allemands qui vont en finale
il
la foule des spectateurs qui affluent
vers le stade pour assister au match a
l'impression de vivre un grand rêve
c'est comme si les cavaliers du xxème
siècle se rencontrer lors d'un tournoi
médiéval mais c'est bien plus que cela
pratiquement tous les spectateurs jouent
ou ont joué au football c'est leur
équipe leur ville leur pays et leur
sport
cette finale angleterre allemagne
deviendra l'une des rencontres les plus
dramatiques de l'histoire du football
3e minute passe de lda a l'air but 1 0
pour les allemands mais le but allemand
semble de bon augure pour la formation
anglaise
jusqu alors dans toutes les finales de
la coupe du monde l'équipe qui a marqué
le premier but a toujours perdu
le football est le sport le plus
apprécié au monde
pourquoi donc parce que les règles sont
simples c'est un sport facile à suivre
le football favorisent la technique au
niveau individuel et le jeu au plan
collectif de multiples tactiques
toujours renouvelables des combinaisons
de mouvements rapides une beauté et une
originalité des gestes de la ruse et
acrobaties des mouvements qui rappellent
ceux d'un balai le foot c'est tout cela
un théâtre où se mêlent g et
divertissement
19e minute corner pour l'angleterre
lorsque dribble deux allemands et un but
par la 55e minute nouveau but de petters
par trente secondes de la fin toute
l'équipe allemande et dans la surface de
réparation des engrais emmerich fait une
passe à l aide pour shaun ehlinger trop
vite le ballon rebondit sur le dos de
webber et puis son pied 2 à 2 à quelques
secondes de la fin
larbitre fait jouer les prolongations
les entraîneurs donnent les dernières
instructions un journaliste enlevée
lâche dément c'est une partie à tomber
raide
dernière minute un tir de hearst touche
la barre transversale
mais comment le ballon at il rebondi
exactement devant derrière ou sur la
ligne de but pour les allemands il n'y a
pas but
larbitre interroge les juges de touche
est valide le but selon les règles le
ballon doit franchir la ligne de but
pour que le but soit valable
la décision de l'arbitré le suisse
dienst dos nu en cette année 1966 à de
nombreuses discussions mais elle ne peut
être modifiée en vertu des règles
sportives
elle est sans appel
les allemands réattaque avec d'autant
plus d'ardeur le titre mondial est en
jeu ce n'est pas le moment de fléchir
nous à la dernière minute alors que les
spectateurs s'apprête déjà à envahir le
terrain lorsque marc un autre but
les anglais sont champions du monde
les glasgow rangers jouent à nurenberg
finale de la coupe d'europe et rangers
contre le bayern de munich
la coupe est organisée par l'union
européenne de football amateur l'uefa
qui contrôle les trois quarts du
football mondial
franz beckenbauer le brésilien bavarois
et l'enfant prodige du football allemand
une passe précise le but est décisif 1 à
0 pour le bayern
la coupe est remise par le président de
l'uefa fi des recherches qui après la
guerre a été l'un des premiers à
encourager la réconciliation avec
l'allemagne une grande victoire pour les
bavarois et pour leur entraîneur le
yougoslave kiosque et 1972 rotterdam la
finale de la coupe d'europe des clubs
champions oppose l'ajax d'amsterdam à
l'inter de milan
l'inter entraînée par internity se
déploie sur le terrain
bordon dans les buts boghni ce bel objet
oriali fakhet joue bertoni qui se
relaiera avec bertini bénigne fruste a
loupé j'ai remplacé par la suite par
pelizza au mazzola et boninsegna dans
les tribunes 70 spectateurs tous les
supporters sont pour l'ajax
deux buts dur classe cruiff vient à bout
de l'inter l'ajax est champion d'europe
dans le stade l'enthousiasmé du public
est à son comble quand il lève la coupe
au ciel le héros cruiff et reçoit une
ovation particulière
les supporters hollandais ne contiennent
plus leur joie ils envahissent les rues
c'est la fête les supporters italiens se
console en mangeant des glaces
kampala capitale de l'ouganda rencontre
pour les éliminatoires de la coupe
d'afrique entre l'ouganda et l'algérie
l'afrique est un continent encore jeune
dans le domaine du football
le jeu des footballeurs est instinctif
mais le public s'enthousiasme pour leur
élégance et leur agilité
denis au but 1 1 marque le but qui mène
l'ouganda la victoire 2 1
en asie les victoires sportives sont
célébrés de manière plus sur les nerfs
quasi rituelles la coupe du roi de
thaïlande est remise à l'équipe
malaisienne après la rencontre disputée
dans la capitale bangkok
toujours à bangkok la finale de la coupe
d'asie oppose l'iran à la corée du sud
l'iran même mais un tir de pas question
me permet à la corée d'égaliser les
asiatiques avec le corps frêle font
preuve d'une résistance inattendue
les iraniens contre attaque pendant les
prolongations
à la 19e minute lironde détentrice du
titre s'impose grâce aux buts de houssen
cannes 2-1
au côté des vainqueurs les équipes
classées deuxièmes et troisièmes
reçoivent également une poupe
mexico stade asticots c'est lui la
véritable star de la coupe du monde 1970
à
le président de la république proclame
le début de la compétition les
soviétiques dispute la première
rencontre avec le mexique premières
manoeuvres tactiques
les dirigeants de l'équipe soviétique
décide de ne pas participer à la
cérémonie d'ouverture
ils veulent éviter à leurs joueurs déjà
incommodés par l'altitude de rester une
heure de plus sous le soleil une vraie
torture
angleterre brésil les vainqueurs de 1966
contre les favorites de 1970
première confrontation entre deux écoles
de football l'européenne et la sud
américain c'est un test
malgré l'excellent style des anglais
celui des brésiliens avec leur
tempérament latino américains s'imposent
le brésil ne semble pas vouloir exhibé
tout son talent mais durant le premier
quart d'heure il prouve sa supériorité
tostao fait une démonstration de sa
virtuosité
pelé il fait une passe à jaillir signaux
qui marque le but décisif
1 à 0 pour le brésil
mexique belgique penalty pour les
mexicains
transformée
suite à cette victoire la nuit sera
longue et les rues mexicaines débordante
de joie
les joueurs russes et uruguayens sont
épuisés les matchs de quarts de finale
se dispute sous un soleil de plomb
et si comme cela ne suffisait pas
larbitre fait jouer les prolongations
les russes souffrent davantage de la
chaleur que les sud-américains koubbi
réussit enfin à marquer un but lors
d'une belle démonstration
1 à 0 pour l'uruguay
les russes soutiennent que le ballon est
sorti du terrain mais l'arbitré n'est
pas de cet avis au début de la rencontre
angleterre allemagne
tout le monde pense que les anglais vont
renouveler l'exploit de 1966 à la 32e
minute les anglais mènent grâce aux buts
de mallory 18 minutes après les jeux
semblent faits beterz marque 2 à 0
beckenbauer profite d'un moment de
distraction des anglais pour marquer un
but de hazard
à 34 ans le vieux capitaine allemand est
le véritable meneur de cette équipe qui
participe à sa quatrième coupe du monde
je n'ai munger centre égalité
et comme à wembley larbitre fait jouer
les prolongations
à la 58e minute de jeu voici enfin le
verdict nul et reçoit le ballon dans la
surface de but et marque pour la main
tous fait 3e but en dansant la polka de
la victoire les italiens mènent contre
l'allemagne 1-0
à la 55e minute de cette demi finale
franz beckenbauer fait une mauvaise
chute
les allemands protestent les capitaines
essaie de calmer les esprits et dans les
dernières minutes passe latérale h hne
ehlinger 1
une fois encore égalité et prolongation
boninsegna pleure c'est la tension et la
fatigue à cause du coup qu'il a pris
beckenbauer doit jouer avec une bande
qui le gêne gerd müller meilleur buteur
de cette coupe renvoie le ballon qui va
ensuite roulé jusque dans les buts
italiens une farce
2 à 1 pour les allemands 79e minute
bur nick est en phase débute égalité de
nouveau 2 à 2
deux minutes après de mangini fait une
passe arrive
l'italie mène 3 à 2 109e minute une tête
de müller intercepte le ballon devant
albertosi 3 à 3 deux minutes plus tard
rivera clos le match 4 à 3 l'italie va
en finale
italie albertosi bourniche serra aux
abdos fac était bertini remplacé ensuite
par julian mat sur la d6 ti domaine
guinea boninsegna qui sera remplacé par
rivera riva brésil felix carlos alberto
brito katsa everaldo clodoaldo géré son
jardinier tostao pelé rivelino à la 17e
minute
il marque le premier but paul est
irrésistible à 30 ans pelé participe à
son quatrième championnat du monde et
c'est sa partie pour ce noir originaire
de l'intérieur du brésil qui a été
cireur de chaussures avant de devenir
millionnaire mexique en 1970 représente
le couronnement d'une carrière
légendaire
à la 37e minute boninsegna égalise pour
l'italie 1
huit minutes plus tard plaie de nouveau
déchaînées il tire trop tard le coup de
sifflet de l'arbitré qui signa la fin de
la première mi-temps a précédé le but
les brésiliens domine le deuxième mi
temps et marque deux autres buts
dernière minute de jeu et dernière
attaque costa jardinot pelé peut tirer
mais il préfère faire une passe à son
capitaine carlos alberto qui est
complètement démarqué but 4 1 pour la
troisième fois le brésil remporte la
coupe du monde
on pourrait la raconter infiniment cette
histoire du football il ya celles qui
appartient au passé mais aussi celle qui
est à venir c'est un sport dans lequel
les supporters glissent souvent
totalement vers le nationalisme un sport
qui fait se lever les présidents et
s'énorgueillit relu nation comment ne
pas se rappeler les prouesses des uns
des autres
lors de la coupe du monde celle des
allemands en 1974 des argentins en 1978
des italiens en 1982 encore des
argentins en 1986
encore des allemands en 1990
des brésiliens en 1994 et des français
en 1998
l'histoire du foot c'est l'histoire
d'hommes qui ont tant donné et en reçu
une histoire qui nous a offert des
moments d'une inégalable joie le temps
passe aussi pour les grands champions
mais leur exploit reste à jamais gravé
dans nos coeurs